okay hello everyone we are back for
another episode of investigating
multi-computation and
multi-computational language design
and the thing that's gotten me excited
about this right now is that
what we are seeing is the analog of
time-like
edges space-like edges and branch-like
edges and even in fact i think rule-like
edges
um
in
the
uh processors
i think we've got two kinds of concepts
we've got
uh data we've got some sort of an
expression which could have lazy parts
that have not yet been
uncovered
and then we've got the whole process of
a computation
it's kind of the analog of nest versus
nastilus nest delivers a a result
but potentially that result could be
lazy in the sense that some parts of it
have not yet been explored
and then there's a second concept which
is the kind of nest list nest graph type
concept which is the the uh the kind of
the the history of how you got there
and that has a lot of complicated things
about you know are we there yet
and things about transversals and
foliations and so on
about uh representing
what counts as a uh as a step in the
evolution and so on
all right that's my preamble i think
nick had a demo to show
yeah over to you
okay
so here
i have a couple of new functions since
tuesday
so first of all i've been thinking of
how to
make a lazy version of any nesting that
we have so the first thing i want to
show is like this next
lazy function is basically we give it a
a function that can produce a list of
even a lazy list and then list of
initial conditions
right
usually you also produce like in the
next graph you also produce
you give it a number of iterations that
you want to go here you don't need that
number it's just lazy that why are there
were there two i mean i'm sorry i don't
understand why there are
two initial values there why isn't that
just a single initial value
well just for generality it could be
just one
okay fine right but i wanna just
generate it give it two so there's gonna
be a list of trees essentially here's a
trees format it has
uh two-year rules right because we have
a function that converts
rules to twist and back
right okay hold on let me let's do basic
framing here could you just do with that
thing where you say yesterday
could you just do a regular nest
actually a regular nest list
it's more well less grappling
well but i want to see nest lists
because i'm trying to understand what
this
okay so that's the on that's the pure
tree-like version
right that nests list that nothing has
merged
yeah i guess it should be something like
that if you nest in it
and maybe even get your name back
[Music]
is that right i don't think that's right
i think you wanted the thing you showed
before i don't think you want the map in
there at all
i think it's literally doing
well you it's just in this way you're
just showing the
branch hole
no well but so in that case could you
make a tree expression out of that or
something
expression tree
yeah i'll do that nest list
isn't this taking advantage of weird
nestability stuff that just happens to
work
yes i mean shouldn't you be doing this
tree
yes probably
is there an ass tree yes there is what
what is an s tree
okay let's take a look at that
and then it should be a map in there
uh i don't understand what's happened
here uh actually look do the last tree
do that's true with the single initial
condition
there you go
okay so that that is now itinerary tree
and then
this first one it's a it's like a strict
version of this lazy tree
here okay could you could you just do
that necessarily with a single one as
the initial condition
okay now
what is that
second oh sorry never mind yeah
it was just an empty list
but this wasn't peeled
i'm confused here
so you could have you could also have
a nest tree lazy
but this
this thing here i don't understand the
arrows what are the arrows
well the arrows
that's the one representation of the
tree right if you have this kind of
one arrow two three
and i think
rules
is it rules three
that can convert it into actual tree
right if you do it yeah okay
all right so
just so i understand so if you can cut
off the nest lazy at a certain level and
then convert it to a tree that would be
helpful
that's basically what this is doing but
instead of doing interactively where
you're clicking in order to expand the
tree
yeah
yes but it's a it's a rules tree
i think it's just it's hard to implement
this with a tree tree and have all this
dynamic stuff going on no no i
understand that i understand that but
i'm just saying that
that the thing you're getting is not the
output of nest it's the output of a
nest tree converted to rules format
is there is there a tree rules function
yes
okay so can you go down to your your
next tree that you just made
yeah okay
okay so that's what this is giving it's
giving the tree rules
of
that nesting okay i'm now beginning to
understand what this is but but really
it's giving
this this lazy tree it's just it's
displaying it in a way that's
reminiscent not the formatting
of tree rules
isn't it exactly tree rules no it isn't
look at look at it it's not exactly
like internally it's some crazy
expression this is just the boxes like
this is just a print form okay okay okay
fine
yeah okay all right
so now there's some traversal order
right
okay so what happens if i want to do a
breadth-first
you know um
if i wanted to take the tree to level
three to breadth first level three or
something
maybe this wasn't the demo you intended
to give i think i understand what this
function is go ahead i was going to go
into other directions so
and then when you have this basically a
lazy tree a list of trees
then you can make it some kind of
treasure so and i have
a
very simple one which is just
goes randomly in the direction that it's
never visited yet right
searching a particular value to try it
and what it produces basically it
produces a new lazy tree
the same but which is as far as it had
to go to get to 15. yes yeah it's like
also what the nodes that visited and the
actual path
and this is this is a position in the
input form
of this particular value
okay
so in that path it was one two three
fifteen
is that correct
why isn't 15 in the path
uh
it's a
it's a powerful like a three path
not not the notes but actual
how you
would move in the tree it's like it's
one two three because it's the first
three then you go to the second okay
there's a picture okay but there's also
the payloads of those nodes which would
in this case be one five fifteen
correct
no one i'm sorry one three four one
three fifteen if you extract like all
the
literally all the sub paths of the final
part
okay
and the exploration because it was
random it also expanded a bunch of other
lazy stuff
and if you're right here that's why that
other tree got unrolled as far as it got
in the world if i run it's going to
probably do a different exploration
okay
okay so
what's that
and that's what basically the whole demo
and i also can show that instead of just
having a tree
i have also a bunch of other nesting
behaviors
but first it would generate
just a linear list of
edges
like in an if you if you have imagine a
graph
that would be an edges
that was produced during the breakfast
church
and similarly in depth
wait wait there are two different things
here there's the output form as edges
and then there's the question of which
part of the tree you're sampling so i
don't understand that
this is
i see this is the this is the traversal
order the tree traversal order
okay so i've got a question let's take
the tree from up above could you take
that tree from up above the complete
tree no no not that one the one we've
actually generated the whole thing no no
no further up further up further up
further
further up further up that one there
that the full nest tree that nest tree
on line 267 the fullness tree that
actual nest tree okay okay yeah
now what i want to see is the tree
traversal order go back down
and let's look at
the set of uh
is there a set of edges can i go
can i traverse this tree
picking up the edges that i visit
in a certain tree traversal order
and that would be for you to answer
well trees don't have edges
so
okay well nick has edges there he has
the one two edge
so okay fine
well okay but what i want to know is how
do you get the thing where nick has gone
from
his lazy tree
depth first that's the visiting order so
i want to see that for an actual tree
you see what i'm saying
isn't that
just like tree map or something
i would think so
i would think so isn't it why isn't it
dream map
oh wait is it returning
i'm not confused what it's returning
is returning a tree or is it returning a
list of vertices in in a particular
order
and when they return edges
or what
it's returning the edges of the tree
that it went down to get to the place
in in depth first order
okay yes
although sometimes
not following an edge you know it'll do
something like it'll go
you know it'll reach the bottom and go
back up to the top so how is that
represented and what nick has
well we'll just follow what it's
actually doing well if there are
actually an end
okay we can model it with
for example
when we
go
[Music]
i don't know 15
otherwise it's just an empty so let's
find it right
yes
okay
i don't understand this but the reason
that christopher just said if you're
doing a depth first or even a breath
first do this depth first
do a depth first version of this
yeah i completely don't understand this
because in depth first
there are plenty of moves that you make
which are you know
scan what are they called vertical
retraces if they were a screen or
something or you're going back
you know what i'm saying it's not so
these edges are not actual edges on the
tree is that correct they're just a
representation of the path
well
there are actual edges in the tree
i don't understand but they're not they
can't be because
they're not that there are there are
places where you go
right to take a concrete example if you
look at that nest tree you have on
screen the one that's already computed
right if you do it depth first you know
you go one two four eight
but then you gotta go back up to four
and then to 12.
oh i guess i guess you do so if you
hadn't go
down depth first
depth
that that's a top down depth first by
the way depth first is usually bottom up
all right so you go eight four two okay
so i guess maybe 12 24
12
again the other 12.
okay so nick how is nick representing
that well maybe maybe if he's visiting
the same so for example if he's visiting
if he's willing to visit vertex four
many times which it looks like i think
he is
then uh
then you can get away with it because
you can go eight to four eight you know
four to twelve twelve to four four to
twenty twenty to four you know etcetera
although
in nest tree okay
tree map can we see this ian could you
could you give us the depth first
visiting order of the nodes of that of
that necessary
tree scan of echo comma the tree
yeah look don't you get a list start
how do you get a list out and use tree
level
okay so fine so let's say tree level
instead of tree tree level forget the
echo
yes and now say treat traversal order
wait a minute what do you have to give
in the tree level argument
okay
to level spec
okay depth that will give you the actual
trees you need to say tree data slash do
all arrow do all arrow data
just data
quote string data
okay
all right so that's the ordering
so
that's what i would expect
nest lazy to return see what one thing
i'm upset about
with with nick's functions here there's
just too much extra wrapping
that in the default case is just going
to prevent people from using the results
anyway
general comment okay but
okay so
i'm very confused nest lazy
i would expect
to produce the same result as nest
but laser is so
it's really necessary lazy
it's kind of hard if you have an actual
infinite tree right
the only difference between
is actually
how the discovery is going where do you
go i know i know i know i realized that
i realized that but i mean i'm saying
that the object that you return
should be an incomplete look if it's
nest it's the incomplete nest okay
what does nest do
you know
go ahead
well i was just gonna say i mean we you
know last time you know we had
nest list and then we had sort of the
infinite nest list right which returns
some infinite list object or something
yes and i think i mean this is the same
this is the same thing it's it's nest
tree or it's nest tree list well no it's
right it's nest tree it's what it is
but then uh you know and it returns some
infinite tree object
and so i don't know right now if we're
talking about the function nest tree you
know the infinite nest tree function or
if we're talking about the this infinite
tree object
or sort of both in some confusing way
okay look listen this is the confusion
that we have before about data
structures versus processes
okay i think these are two separate
things there is the what is the output
nest
versus how did it get there as well as
the output that's nest list
next tree nest graph those are all how
did it get there type things that are
slightly more sophisticated and some
more similar to what we're going to do
here
although although i would argue that
something like infinite nest list or
whatever it's called is is not just how
did it get there compared to nest
because it you know
because never gives
right because there isn't an infinite
nest because it doesn't make sense i
don't know what your data i mean you
could have an infinite nest if you could
think of a data structure that would be
queryable but i just don't think it
makes sense
a confusing thing to say would be to say
that fixed point is like infinite nest
yeah that's what i was gonna say
no but like that's a that's a weird
analogy i think
i don't know right because well because
infiniteness list can work in cases
where it diverges but fixed point can
only and quote unquote infinite nest
only works that converges
look i agree infinite nest makes no
sense for a non-halting computation
for non-converging computation
i mean fixed point you give it an
infinite loop it's not halting it's just
it converges
yes which is why i say it's a different
concept really i mean it's it's just
it's it's uh
yeah well okay i claim
we are used to single-way computation it
is a little less obvious to me what
infinite nest means
in the case of a multi-weight
computation
and i think it might mean something even
when
uh i i i reserve judgment on whether it
could mean something
well the question is how do you
represent the output of a multi-way
computation anyway i mean right now we
would do it with something like a list
or maybe a tree or a multi
that's what multi is multi is
the you know the multi doesn't represent
the result multi represents sort of the
the object you know you you then call
something like normal or something you
do some query to multi to sort of okay
i'm gonna make a claim i'm gonna make a
claim that there are actually two
objects we need we need multi and we
need some kind of computation object
that represents the history
okay and multi i claim is like the
analog of a quantum superposition it is
a slice across these trees
across potentially a multi-way tree
um
that or you know
it's it's a slice across
across the tree
that represents
the
a particular transversal of this tree am
i making sense
and
okay so i'm going to give an example
where i don't think it's hopeless let's
take one of these combinators
where
in the multi-way graph
um
many
okay in the multi-weight graph there is
a terminating path
in the multi-way graph and it terminates
on something definitely confluent and so
on and there are lost in the woods paths
that go off and um uh and don't
terminate okay and i can imagine
something where we could have and it
could be a very useful thing we could
have a function that gives you the
terminating part
and tells you there are other
non-terminating parts or other parts
where it doesn't know if it terminates
see what i'm
saying people understand what i'm saying
i mean it says they basically run
something like this laziness tree and
then it returns sort of all of the
leaves that were finished and then you
know kind of maybe tells you about all
the
quote-unquote leaves that still have
stuck below them but which hasn't
completed
it is the look i claim
it's a multi
where some parts of the multi are
unfinished
some parts of them multi-like black
holes they're done time has stopped
and some parts of the multi are still
alive and kicking
does that make sense nick do you
understand what i'm saying
well
how is it different from this thing for
example there's some black holes that
are finished
yeah i'm just saying the data structure
has got to not be some weird newly
constructed thing it's got to be
something where if you said okay
maybe i'm just objecting to the print
form of the state of structure
i'm just saying the thing is a multi
where some part of the multi is a black
hole that's furnished and some part is
still alive and well
and you can keep going with it so you
could say run this multi another few
steps
no and the multi would not contain
necessarily
the multi would contain its state but it
would not necessarily contain
information about how to keep running it
did you see what i'm saying
whereas the computation object will keep
information about how to keep running it
well
this this kind of con contains all the
information maybe
it contains
a bunch of other
ways
too much information
basically
only this function that we provided it
and how to
go
like forward
it's not too much
almost like the minimal data that it's
possible to describe the all the future
results of applying this function to all
the
its children
i don't know
i'm going back i'm sorry
going back to steven's comment on
computation versus visualization i was
thinking what's the relation with ian's
uh
three outline in which you have openers
and you keep clicking on the things you
want to open
yeah that's
that's just another
nicely
nice formatting that can be done for
this object
because it's essentially also a tree
so if i had this similar thing
right
i guess my point is that this idea of
clicking and getting more and more
information progressively
is not necessarily related to something
infinite
so perhaps there is a way of combining
both things
into
separating the actual data structure
from the visualization part
do sort of mean though that that
i
mean surely i mean
it totally makes sense that if you had
something like this multi you know nest
lazy thing that that the nick has
visualizing it in a way like this tree
outline i think would be fantastic
but
it seems like the underlying i mean
at least the the top level tree outline
function you know
you know makes certain assumption you
know you're giving it a tree object that
works in a certain way right and it
doesn't have any rules about well if you
click on this triangle it might have to
recompute this whole tree or something
although that is something that we want
so john fulton
for something called tree view
and that would be useful for things like
a file browser like right now in the
prototype build there's file system tree
but that requires you to gulp kind of
like an entire directory and all of its
sub directories into memory before you
can create the outline
but you would like be able to produce
outlines that are basically a laziness
laziness tree so you click on an opener
and only then do you read what files are
in that directory
well so that's probably almost exactly
you know
like uh the you know the thing that nick
is demoing here right
and i guess it's it's sort of a pure
visualization object
in that case i i'm guessing
but
yeah i mean we need we need lazy nest
tree for
for the visualization we need it for
like streaming transformations
streaming transformation
well so for example like doing an xml to
json transformation without needing to
to
first build an entire tree in memory
and then converting just converting as
you go
so that's interesting and that's not
unrelated to leonard's chunking business
right
yep precisely
okay so let's review this again so what
we're saying is
um
okay i'm sorry i i want to i want to go
through this again this concept of
the multi
which is the essentially quantum state
does that is that making sense to people
it's the slice it's what you get
at a particular quotes time whatever
that means or whatever that transverse
thing that you're you're looking at is
and that is distinct from
the computation object
that represents the whole history does
that make any sense
the multi-object fundamentally
represents a set of different
possible positions okay
not a tree
not a thing that tells you here's right
choices i made necessarily it's just it
fundamentally represents the set you
might be able to query it in other ways
but but that's what it represents
right and that's set
okay the the point is that's set
i i don't think you can even deduce the
branchiograph from it because you don't
know anything about its history but one
thing that is true
is given a multi
you can always keep going with the same
time evolution that got you to that
multi you can keep going on the multi
you know
applying the time evolution operator
again does that make sense to people
doesn't that just mean you keep
computing with the same foliation that
you had that yielded that particular
slice yes for example well i don't know
it's
the same foliage i mean you keep going
that's a that's a slice that's a
transversal now you keep going applying
the time evolution operator
and it's up to you how thick you want
the different parts of that time
evolution operator to be you'll get
another transversal but the point is
just like this is a faux initial
condition if you understand what i'm
saying
the multi is something usable as an
initial condition
does that make sense to you
well yeah because you don't have that
it's more than just a set of events
because event
basically holds both its input and
no i'm not talking about events i'm
talking about mistakes
what's that
well you have to at least store the
actual history one step
behind it
why well branch or graph for example i
know i'm saying you can't derive the
branch shield graph from the malt city
well if it said that's what i said
what
if it's a set of events then you can
i'm okay fine fine
but i'm i'm saying there is a concept of
the thing that lives in a slice
possibly we can thicken the slice but
the whole point is we're not storing the
whole computation history it's just like
nest it's just a result
does that make sense
and we can keep going applying the time
evolution operator to that thing
right to get another just the result
thing
does that make sense i mean it's like
saying with nest graph okay nest graph
is a history but in nest graph you could
look at the outer boundary of nest graph
that's more like the thing that we're
imagining this multi is
stephen why do you want the history to
be discarded is it just for purposes of
simplicity
yes so okay want to make sure we
understand this is the current structure
of space for example this is the current
hypergraph
this is a bunch of hyperedges and it's
it's just it's the current it's the
notion of the world as it is now it's
just branch-like hyper surface but it's
but you don't have anything that came
before it and so that's right and as
you're saying that could serve as an
arbitrary initial condition because it's
basically a historical so you could just
start history from there if you want it
yes yes but i'm just trying to clarify
what it is because it's like nest list
right you can go nest
you know you get to a result then you
feed that into nest list you can store
history for a while then you get the
results of that you can consider that
the result and then you can store
history and so on i'm just trying to
break up the different concepts here so
that we have the most important things
the thing i'm not liking about the
things that i'm seeing here is you know
nick has a giant swiss army knife
of you know things that are being
returned by these functions and i'm
saying i don't think that's what we want
i think we want a function you know
there can be a function that returns the
swiss army knife so to speak
okay but we want functions that are much
simpler
that just return you know like like we
could have said
okay every function that we have that
returns kind of diverse outputs like let
me give you an example find shortest
tour it's super annoying
that it returns the length of the tour
and then the list of of tour you know
visits okay every single time i use it
i'm annoyed by the fact that i have to
say first last whatever right
i would have been much happier now in
that case i i don't know what the right
way to do that one is and maybe that one
in modern times we should give it
another argument a note to be made for
lcc probably about that that allows you
to select one of those two things and
the default probably should have been
a um
uh see look at that see see that yeah it
could be an association or something and
then right it should be in this
youtuber
by your general point though but i mean
i think i agree you know functions
should be should be kind of
fairly minimal
a lot of the time but the objects
should be pretty you know are often
pretty swiss army knives right yes
that's right that's what i think and my
point here is i think there is an object
there is a there is a
you know a function
thing like like
you know
i think multi is a new concept like a
list like a set like a whatever
that is useful that is very minimalist
and a computation object has lots of
hair in it go ahead but see now i mean
one one thing is though that
well
right i mean it blurs a little bit when
you have stuff like graph
where graph is fundamentally you know
that's the swiss army knife data
structure
but it also is kind of a function right
because you know it has several
constructors and you know and you can uh
give it lots of complicated options and
so on
so i mean there are some cases where
it's a little bit
unclear fair enough fair point okay but
the thing i'm trying to understand here
is
okay we're trying to okay nick what are
you showing here
the the multi object that i have already
which is well maybe it's not
minimalistic as you want but it contains
some rules how it can progress to a new
multi object
okay
right
okay but
let's just let's just
zoom out for a second to the overall
picture the overall picture is
we have
you know
i'm still a little bit confused
by the relationship of laziness to all
this other stuff
okay because we've got
laziness and multiness what is the
relationship
or are they orthogonal concepts i think
it's just that multiness there come you
know
some of the things you'd like to return
from some of these multi-way functions
are things like the multi-way system you
know as a tree
but fundamentally it is often an
infinite tree
and so that's why or it's at least a
very big tree
and that's why you know we're talking
about lazy stuff as a natural way of
representing it okay all right so then
we've got three different concepts that
we're dealing with here okay we've got
lazy we've got multi and we've got
computation object
i think
am i making sense
yeah well okay yeah
computational object would be the thing
that we're up
for example
there's that fine thing
yeah it's like for example this is a
computation on the multi-way data
structure
that's right that's exactly on the
computational object data structure
or multi-computation it could be called
multi-computation multi-computation
object whatever it is
it's i would favor
just having it be a computation object
and that computation object is the raw
material on which trace graph for
example can operate
now the computation object would store
enough
to be able to extract from it something
like a trace graph
does that make sense
sure basically like here
this is the history so you can trace the
on the right multi way again
this is yet a different thing no this is
no no because what i'm saying is
just like trace in its rather you know
inadequate way
is a complete representation of a
computation
right that's what we want computation
object to be that has nothing to do with
the path the path i don't want any of
this crud in the path i just want the
freaking path if i say find me the path
i want to see the path i don't want to
see any other extra crud i just wanted
to see the path
right
yeah
and um
you know because that's what you know a
function called find path
finds the path
to you know and in that case it would
probably be we might even apply
find path
i i don't know whether it would make
sense to say
find path of the computation object from
a to b
i don't know that's actually find path
or whether that's something different
does that make sense
right but none of this extra crud none
of this extra credit is relevant
if it's fine path it's finding a path
and that's all it's doing
okay
so it's good just to tell the path
yeah that's what we want just a path
nothing else right if we want to find
something else then we should ask for
something else right because it's really
important that we not have functions
that return a bunch of extra crud
it will just be unusable it will just
mean that you have to you know i mean
that's one of the things for all of us
problems
the current design of multi-way
graph
or multi-way system in the function
repository it does actually return
fairly clean things and that's good and
it doesn't return
you know a giant
sort of uh
you know
you know a swiss army knife or whatever
from which you then have to extract
something and extract something and
extract something you see what i'm
saying
and i think that's a really good thing
well barf can be a default but you can
agree that sometimes
the other things are also useful
sure that's fine but i don't think it
should come out from a thing called find
path
i mean maybe maybe it has an extra
argument that gives some other things i
don't know
but yes those things should be findable
but i'm saying not you know it's it's
very important that there's a very clean
version of what comes out for these
things so it's actually usable by people
right and so they don't have to
understand one of the problems we're
going to run into okay we've had many
meetings about multi-computation and so
on okay this subject is not simple
right and if you look at the you know
this is this is on the higher end of
conceptual difficulty of things that
that um and so therefore any time you
throw people this giant pile of stuff
with you know
lazy structures and this and that and
the other they're just gonna drown
they're going to give up same thing that
we found with breadth first search right
now if you go to the brett's first
search page nobody's using it because
it's too complicated
scout
yeah brush first scan right
we can't see that window but if you if
you're clicking on just one thinking
right i mean you know nobody's using
this it's too complicated right we've
got to factor this in such a way that it
actually provides
you know you see what i'm saying
this is not a good thing to this is not
a good design
right so i mean again
you know
you know this is our challenge is to you
know
is to factor this functionality so that
people can actually use it and so the
conceptual model
is
okay so let's review what the conceptual
model is again do you want me to share
it or do you have more stuff to share
oh that that's it
oh christ
um
okay so now wait a minute i had a um
you said i had notes from before
okay let's i'm gonna make another set of
notes because i think apparently
okay let's factor again
i mean
we seem to be looping around the same
things over and over again which is kind
of frustrating
i mean
okay
all right so let's make another set of
notes here
where am i putting these put it in sw
notes
has anybody looked at these sw notes
that are here have you been reviewing
these are these relevant to what we're
talking about right now
by the time we're version 26 we need to
go through an inventory what's there try
and pick out and summarize what we've
already got
i mean we've done we had done that at
some point right we looked at all the
notes from these multi-computation
language design meetings and we did try
and summarize from that and we did build
that
so i claim there are three basic things
there's lazy data structures
there's um
multiness
and there's computation objects
and there's
and basically there's
functions
on computation objects
okay so another thing that was added
is
is something a little bit different from
this which is the thing that we were
talking about about subsets for example
okay which i claim is a little bit
different that's more like
uh
well i don't know is that different i
mean it's like lazy
lazy iteration functions or something am
i making sense
right yeah
we can make a
whole bunch of objects like that
okay so let's look at what is a lazy
data structure what what is the typical
example of a lazy data structure it's
like range of infinity now maybe this
lazy exploration functions
is the same deal that it's like subsets
of range of 20 or something right
that is the data structure it's list
it's just the different generators for
lazy list
right yes these are not data structures
these are functions you're talking about
these are constructors for a single
object okay this is constructors
for
lazy
objects
specifically lazy list
i'm not sure that's the name we're going
with but in this case it's lazy list i
think it's important though to i mean
we're just talking about functions
versus data structures
so i think you know
yeah okay so i mean this is potentially
a lazy of range or whatever
let's say
something like this
right
and then
we have to have
that's the constructor but now we have
to now we have
operations
on lazy lists
so one of the things that is different
for a lazy list
well it depends how it's cached i mean
you know we could do something which
just says
how do you index this next object thing
right you've got a lazy list and it
feels very car color-ish um
uh
you know are there
are there cursors
on the lazy list
you see what i'm saying
so in other words is there a notion of
i'm like a stream as there is than a
stream
well that would be another data
structure not at least i think so at
least
by definition i think it's a data
structure that
lazy list that have just the first and
next
or rest basically okay all right well
then that's i mean that's one model and
i'm not sure exactly what the interface
should be i doubt it should involve
cursors though
i mean here's here's one of the the big
thing i mean this is one of the things i
think was useful from from you know
being a summer school project for
example was the fact that there are lots
of different data structures you can
imagine having like oh i'm going to have
this data structure it's sort of like a
you know i have a lazy list and you
might have a lazy tree then you might
have a lazy dag and you might have a you
know whatever the problem is a lot of
those objects or i have a lazy list with
a cursor in it whatever right a lot of
those objects don't have existing they
have no analogy to to not to you know
eager data structures you know where
those eager data structures have
functions right so you'd have to invent
a whole new sort of set of functions to
interact with them
i think it's much it's much more useful
if you basically say this is a lazy data
structure that is entirely analogous to
a list it's semantics or exactly that as
a list but it's lazy
you know
then you get to inherit all the list
functions so for example lists don't
have cursors so i'd argue you know you
shouldn't have cursors either
at least not visibly
right i mean we could by the way have a
data structure that has a list with the
cursor in
in the data structure
collection i don't know what that would
be
how is that not a list and a number next
to it somewhere else that's what it is
yeah that's pretty much what it is it
just stores it but it stores it
hold on like a stream it does the same
thing that a stream does it has a seek
you know it's a it's a stream like list
because the stream knows the stream
pointer
see what i'm saying sure i guess i mean
if there are if there's a set of
operations that that could be useful on
it then sure i guess you could have it
right but i think we should look at that
i think it's it's a it's a it's the
analog of a stream but for an in-memory
object
i mean that that's exactly what years
ago
what the heck are those things called
we have a
oh my gosh what is it called in the
stream system
there is a um
uh
what is it called somebody must know
this don't tell me the functionality is
that useless
there's a you can get an in-memory
stream what is it called
this is pathetic documentation oh string
to stream that's right
string to stream
do you see what i'm saying yeah
sure sure
i just think streams have not really
been a super
winning concept i mean they've only
really happened you know when you're
doing really low level io stuff i i
understand that but string to stream was
an attempt to make a cursor based
uh and i it seems to me this is a would
be a good thing to have an identity
structure collection a a string to
stream
data you know
stream
lists to yeah yeah right right right
could also have
list stream so it will be
these will be two
i like this i think that there could you
know two data structures um
well but in the in this context of lazy
it would be just lazy of list
it would be lazy it wouldn't be no it
wouldn't be roman no it wouldn't be
no that's the whole point that's what we
keep on saying the whole point is if we
say a lazy list is just like a list it
doesn't have a current element pointer
right i mean this is a separate
discussion that we're talking about
right now so from lazy lists i mean
we're just talking generally about
whether it would be nice to have
some sort of
basically streams for lists
which exactly i'm saying what roman is
making the mistake of saying that that's
what a lazy list is because it isn't
that's not what it is what i mean is a
lazy version of a normal list
yes but that's not different than this
that's not this
this is something which contains a
stream pointer
right a list does not contain
a current position pointer
you see what i'm saying
but i i wanted to show this inactive
example because i think this is not what
i would call lazy this is some sort of
symbolic list
in which we can have length n and then
we can do some operations
but i wouldn't call this lazy for the
same reason you are saying this this
asset has an iterator pointer
a current pointer
what has occurred this doesn't what what
am i saying a lazy list is not a list
for the pointer or do we disagree about
that
that's not what a lazy list is a lazy
list is just something where not
everything has been evaluated that's my
point of view
and i think with the right i think it's
the correct model for us to provide to
people and in other words it's a list
where were you to ask for the millionth
element it would just give it to you
and you know assuming it could and if
you were to ask for the millionth
element again it would behind the scenes
have cached that list because it knows
that it doesn't have to recompute that
these are sort of implementations
very close to what leonard's streams are
because they are
kind of
caching lazy lists
with exactly that it's it's again it's
got stream pointers again
i'm not sure
terms i mean i think
well maybe
there is no string
in a thing we call a list
there's no pointer and a thing we call a
list it just has it has indices but it
does not have a current index pointer
remember making sense there is no notion
of a current index you know i've got a
list here
i'm not sure there's much disagreement
about this and i think i think we all
kind of
agree on that i mean it's just
right i mean i mean there's other
there's other semantic things that has
to be the same too like for example you
know
uh it has to be immutable right you
can't have mutable opera lists generally
are not immutable for instance well okay
so behind the scenes this would be
mutable a lazy list would behind the
scenes be mutable
for the purposes of caching it might be
invisibly mutable right that's
irrelevant we're just talking about the
the visible semantics
yep
okay so so
let's see if we agree
okay
the concept is that a lazy list
is something that can be symbolically
described by something like this
potentially
and that would return
i mean these names are no good but but
that would return a lazy list
which is a somewhat opaque thing
okay were we to say normal of that lazy
list if it were finite it would just
return the list
am i making sense
within that lazy list if we ask for
element one two three four five it will
be able to generate those elements but
there is no notion of the current
element
do we do we agree about this
and yes i mean that only you consequence
of immutability i mean the other
the other thing would be iterators which
are mutable which is something could be
something different
bo what do you mean by that you mean a
thing with the pointer yes yeah i mean
an iterator is is a
it's a mutable object that produces
elements of something
one at a time
but you cannot go back and
so it changes its internal state every
time
so they are very useful for example for
combinatorial generators where instead
of generating a whole
large set of say trees or so you and you
only look at one of them
that's a different concept okay yes so
this thing here
would be
a function which gives us you know it's
basically the the
um
you know it's something not very
familiar in our you know it's a next
element
function it's a next element thing
that
could take a list inside it
and it will always every time or the
heck you know and i don't like it it's a
little bit like it's a it's a little bit
like take drop but really it's first
rest first rest for a function except it
isn't because it's mutable no i i know i
know i'm saying sorry i mean the
immutable version would be something
like first rest you can get a similar
so this is it's something like
you know as append to
appends to a list an element
okay this would be
uh
i mean right right now basically the
only immutability that we have is either
in the data structures framework which
is a different thing or in the symbol
table and this is
this is not in the symbol table so i
think this would be a new kind of
mutability that we don't have right now
well it could be in the symbol table
because we could say
internally there could be some symbol
hiding somewhere inside no i don't think
i understand behind i think it could
just be
if you have a symbolic expression
and you
call a replace that would it be you just
generated a new version it's immutable
the whole list
not just the part of it right yeah yeah
yeah
what if we have some mutable version of
replace list replace ad for expressions
in general
well remember the only way as
christopher's pointing out the only way
we can do mutability is to anchor it on
the stumble table
actually we have that that thing that i
don't think has this ever been
what is that thing called the thing that
allows you to have a mutable
what is that called we we had this
notion of expression object did we not
did we ever
did we ever introduced that in the end
are you talking about experts
no no no no no much longer ago this
concept of a mutable
anonymous ex object
right like a symbol but it isn't a
symbol it's a construct that you can
make with the uuid
so there's something a little bit like
that i think there's a compiler data
structure called value
that you can use to do
similar things so you can have a value
data structure you can set it and you
can get it
and it effectively does that
no the thing that i'm talking about
what's that
are you thinking of
no i'm not no i'm not i'm not
roman do you know what i'm talking about
now
the only thing that came to my mind is
is that compiler thing
okay what we had and i don't know what i
mean i can go do a search for this we
had this notion i think it was called
expression object okay and what it is
it's an anonymous symbol
do you understand what i'm saying
it's just an expression object with a
uuid
that is assignable to
does that make sense
no
hmm
do you understand what i'm saying it's a
thing
oh gosh i i think it's i think it sounds
like it's identical to this data
structure
and everything
it probably is yeah
i mean this was a much earlier thought
and we i don't think we ever came back
to it
let's see if i can do a search here
um
let's see
okay 2017 2018 2019
mutable object was the proposed name
it was in astounding notes expression
object
look at that there it is
oh gosh 2018
okay create mutable object delete object
etc
this looks i mean even the api of this
thing looks like data structures and i
noticed that one of the notes had tw in
its title so i'm guessing this turned
into the data structures yeah and i
think we never came back to this
particular idea but i think it exists
okay yes okay right in the compiler
there's this create reference thing
which is almost certainly
you know where the okay this this i
think was done but it's just called the
value data structure you just go to the
documentation it is exactly what you're
talking about
okay
i think it needs to be better exposed
then
i'm not sure about that because i think
it's not i think it's a non-idiomatic
way to program
i mean there's some cases where it's you
know where it can be convenient for
stuff like caching especially but i i
generally think it's it's you know look
at that it's the very very first thing
on the data structures page yes yes
i think people reach for this sort of
thing a bit too
too readily
because it's something that you use a
lot in other more mutable programming
languages but which
you know
i don't think we should make too easy to
use
okay well i think you're right that this
is the thing
okay so that would be where the iterator
object would live is something like this
right
i mean all the data structures by the
way are mutable like that right sorry
almost all of them are so well maybe we
should have an iterated data structure
to take care of this thing that we're
talking about right now
i mean there isn't just one iterator i
mean but i'm
i'm fairly advanced in my design for
for an iterator system and
we'll hear more about it at the
conference in the fall
well
what's the idea for how it would
interact with anything we're talking
about here
well it is kind of
i mean a little bit orthogonal because
because of the mutability because every
time you ask for the next element i mean
you consume it
and so it's really
as the name implies the idea is
to iterate over it for example to
iterate over all trees and test each one
of them for certain properties
yeah but as as many people have been
saying here that's not a particularly
natural thing in our language
yeah but it can be for example it could
i know you can graft it on but it's not
obvious you want to
well but other if you don't have it then
you either need
to have a loop where you always call a
function to create the next element
or you need to no you don't you if you
have a scan over this for example
you're throwing away each element as you
get to it but you're successively
visiting elements
yes i mean you can do
you can do the same things
but the one advantage of
mutable data structures is the compiler
interface
okay but we don't mutable data
structures are really alien to our
language setup
so i think we should try to avoid them
but i think that you can get like if
we've got this and you know for example
let's imagine we do a scan of an if blah
blah blah
of a so
whatever it is right
onto
lazy of subsets
that wouldn't allow us to select right
but it depends what you're doing on it
no if you saw then you and you reap them
then it's just select no it depends what
you're doing it
well whatever you can do that okay you
might want to make a decision i see the
problem is
what if you make a decision about
whether to go on based on what you got
back
that's a scan while type idea right
yeah which we don't have
or we just use a while loop with an exit
condition or
yeah right okay fine
but okay let's come back to where we're
really trying to get to here okay so
we've got this notion
so this is not clear whether we're doing
this right now this isn't the although
the thing that we definitely do want
okay in this case
we want to be able to scan over that and
that might require
our own sort of special code
for being able to do you know so if this
was more complicated than just lazy
subsets if this was a a more complicated
expression
that we had made lazy
and that we that is in fact a very long
list
we might want to be able to scan over it
with
you know
in some lazy in some lazy way but the
the the basic point here
right where where it is getting an
element on demand
does this make sense to people that the
the that the thing outside of this
the question is
one thing one could do is everything's
lazy until there's an explicit release
an explicit kick to stop being lazy
an explicit wake-up
do you understand what i'm saying
well
every time it calls for an elevator it's
an explicit wake-up
no but that's not obviously the correct
thing i mean it could be the case that i
say this
stub one million okay
and that could be that the lazy just
eats that and the whole thing is then
lazy
and that it requires
something that says wake up
naturally evaluate it
like hold and release hold you see what
i'm saying
but why would you
why would you do that in the first place
do what
well
provide that 10 to the six but say oh
don't do it
if you don't need it then
just do it when you need it i mean
fair enough okay so then let's let's
loop back around
okay
there are potentially many functions
that could be made lazy as in
don't do it and don't actually evaluate
the function until you need the result
right
so implementationally
we would have essentially a table of
lazy versions of these things where this
would have some kind of generalized up
values that says if you need the end
element we might have a special
algorithm to getting to get you the nth
element
does that make sense
yes
i mean the idea
is to
say okay we have these lazy lists so now
let's look at all functions
that take a long list as argument
and work in such a way that no no we
don't have a label
we don't look at this actual thing it is
not the lazy list it is a lazy
variant of this function
okay so is it the result the with the
result the result of this
expression is a lazy list of
okay all right fine so the one thing we
have that we feed to other functions is
the lazy list we have generators for the
lazy list
which
are
lazy variants of ordinary functions
am i making something yeah i mean all
the functions that produce lists are
candidates for
lazy versions that produce lazy lists
right range
constant away nest list are they
probably the most important ones
table
the same thing will be true so do we
want a lazy tree as well
sure
i think so
okay so
let's take a look at lazy the
combinatorial generators are an
important class right
now
generators they're generators that
they're part of this story here yes
lazy constructs we've got lazy list
we can imagine whoops i typed lazy
string but i meant lazy lists but we
also have the concept of lazy string
will be another one
where the most likely source of a lazy
string would be a file
making sense
yes but i mean more generally if
the
uh reader's lazy realist would be the
closest analog because that is it what
lazy weed list
no no that's not what this is no these
are constructs
these the constructs okay okay yes okay
so lazy needless that you see these are
the questions
yes okay this has a you know this for
example might have a constructor
of lazy read list yes
okay now what other things would be our
lazy constructs we'd also have lazy
graph presumably
well the problem with lazy well maybe
you could have lazy graph i mean the
hard thing is that
it's sort of uh
in these other cases we have a you know
we've sort of picked a frontier i mean
for example with lazy list
maybe we could have a you know we could
have a lazy list that's lazy you know it
starts at the end and goes to the
beginning
two-dimensional eg
1d lists
are straightforward
they're not you think they're
straightforward but they're not we've
arbitrarily chosen that the first part
of the list will be concrete and that
the the arbitrary part on the right it
could be on the left
yeah i agree i agree but i don't think
that's i think it's reasonable
but imagine a 2d list
where there's a more complicated region
that is filled in versus not filled in
right in practice
at least with the current i mean we've
talked about having other kinds of
infinite arrays but at least with this
lazy list thing i think if you had a 2d
one it would just be you know from the
top left kind of thing yeah uh fine but
that's
sorry
what is a 2d list
a lazy list of lazy lists
by me we could imagine having another
data structure for
genera generic lazy arrays but that's
another let's not get into that right
now because that's a
complicated question but for graphs
sorry go ahead
i was going to say that with inactive of
table we can nest them
and then we can do i goes to n and j
goes from i to
something else
you can have a rocket of rays and things
like that
so actually
d understands those things already
right i mean i think that's a different
like the the reason why i'm saying you
know we shouldn't talk too much about
lazy arrays because i think that
that if we had i think that a lot of the
applications of lazy arrays are pretty
different like i mean with that table
thing
you know it's very natural to basically
make something we have a generator
function where you give it a position
and it returns you the element which is
useful for all sorts of things but it's
fundamentally very different from how a
lot of these other lazy operators were
talking about work
um i mean for example you can do random
access
much more efficiently and and so on
but but sorry i was just bringing this
up though to say that lazy graph i think
it's not clear how it grows i mean it's
not clear where the concrete part is and
how it goes outward and there are things
about you know
uh
yeah i think it's
yeah yeah
sorry which one lazy graph yeah lazy
graph yes yeah that's non-trivial that's
what we've been talking about about
foliations and all that kind of thing i
agree
but lazy trees i think are well defined
but like you know there's an obviously
they're not well lazy they've got to
treat reversal order they've got to
treat reversal ordering
no but it's obvious how the functions
it's obvious where the concrete part is
and where the lazy kind of cut off bits
would go right we're doing it so that
the root is concrete and that the leaves
can be can be lazy did i forget to
invite brad
brad to this meeting
i can ping him right now
we forgot how to do that
okay but but i think that trees it's
clear where the concrete part is that's
not the case with graphs it is for dags
it's a little clearer
sure but we don't have a dag data
structure i know that i know that i
don't know if if we should generate we
should invent a dag a concrete dag data
structure and make a whole library of
functions for it before we should uh
make a lazy one
think we're going to need a laser graph
because i think it's deeply related to
computational objects that's the problem
i mean i'm just trying to imagine
you know
oh like i'm trying to think of functions
that operate on graphs so if you had an
infinite graph object let's say it
starts at a vertex and it kind of grows
outward in every direction
and it's guaranteed that there won't be
you know
they're also the same situations you can
get
because
i'm sure
it doesn't matter what the graph looks
like i mean it's just any graph right
you start at vertex and you grow outward
or you start some seeds or something
yeah so first of all i think you have to
make assumptions about for instance
hoping that oh i'm not going to follow a
path and it's going to lead me back to
where i started
because like for example
you're allowed to have loops but but but
you don't want to have a loop where you
think you know that my degree is 4 but
then some later vertex is actually going
to connect back and actually my degrees
yeah i understand that i agree
but then the question is okay even if
you have constraints like that
what is vertex list going to return you
want it to return some infinite list
but it's like
a vertex degree
or something like i i just think these
are like
i understand vertex degree because
the generator the nest graph
might not have merged yet you might have
the wrong answer
right so so um
uh
okay so let's take an example
of nest graph of my favorite example the
x goes to
you know
uh 2x
x plus one
and let's start that off from one and go
three steps
actually let's go two steps
see it looks like a tree
that looks like sure
sure i mean
you've got a particularly easy k each
dad you know x uh x minus four something
like that or x minus three
in order to make it
more even that case works it's it's
joined up there okay this is a dag it's
not a true not a graph
and you have to go further
the point being that this has edges
that you know where it merges after many
steps if that makes sense yup um no i
agree
but by me i'm just i'm just thinking
i think
right it might be there might be some
kind of infinite graph thing we can have
but i think it's not clear how any of
its operations will work and it's not
obvious i think there are different
choices we could make but
let's not let's not
let's not chase this particular one i
think we're going to need it but let's
not chase it right now
in terms of lazy constructs here
i really would like to find an
alternative to the lazy word
um
uh but any case procrastinating
the
uh dormant
doorman's tits has too much
yeah
it's too much it's un
you know it's undone basically on
but you know we've got all these
different things inactive
you know et cetera et cetera et cetera
you know we've got
okay so we've got here's the question of
name for
lazy
because what we've got right now is
we've got hold
we've got inactive
we've got
deferred what other things do we have
implicit would be something
no no no
no no roman what i'm listening here is
the things we already have okay concepts
we already thinking about the possible
name for lazy
and implicit is not going to cut it
because you've got too many mathematical
implicit things
but what else do we already have what's
that
we already have implicit region
yeah we have implicit is not going to
work
so what what else do we have what other
constructs concepts do we have
hold holds evaluation for a release
inactive
changes the data structure hold is just
a wrapper
you know inactive implies you're going
to activate it though
yeah it's a pure wrapper i'm just
listing what we have so we know what the
difference is to what we're talking
about
inactive
changes the innards of the data
structure
actually that's an activate
yeah an action is just a real problem
yeah it's just a rapper
but it's a
so you know what we've got here
is again it's a you know lazy
is a rapper
much like inactive right
or you can also say that it's like a
hold
also
it's like a similar wrapper
no it isn't because it's a head wrapper
in the way that we're imagining it here
right
oh
here yeah
i think it has to be a head wrapper
doesn't it
making sense
yeah so so what's the real difference
between lazy and inactive because we
know that inactive has a problem which
is that because it removes the
attributes and we have positive
attributes like listable
and negative attributes like hold first
by removing the negative attributes like
whole first it's actually activating
things and and this is a problem with
inactive so i wonder whether this is the
main difference
between lazy and inactive
is what the next basically just
so i think the problem we have discussed
other times is is holding
with inactive that inactive lets things
evaluate and so it's activating things
actually
yeah that's weird
but it removes other attributes like
listable which is good
well your
your question is could lazy
but you see no we we want lazy of this
to evaluate to some kind of
i mean yeah i mean for for constructors
that do not need the whole attributes
this would work
another approach would be to wrap lazy
around the whole constructor call so
it's a lazy of range of infinity
yeah what and the last option though is
to have lazy range be the symbol which
honestly i think makes the most sense
because it's the same thing as like you
know we have nest listening of nest tree
you know we have we don't have tree of
nest of blah blah blah
right this is fundamentally going to be
okay how many lazy objects do we need
and we talked about this a bit last time
i was estimating a pretty low number but
then we came up with some other ones i
think it's still going to be you know
in the neighborhood of tennis let's
let's get some sense of this okay
so let's look at core language on the
list but it's not even about the number
of them i mean it's that you know if
just because we had a bunch of
constructors for trees doesn't mean
we're just going to have a bunch of you
know the normal list functions but then
we're going to have
tree of nest of blah blah does this i
mean it's just let's just make different
things okay let's make a list of um
uh potentially lazy
variants
okay we've got lazy range
and a constant away
wait wait wait we're gonna go down this
list okay we're gonna go down this list
we're not just gonna jump
okay so
lazy table right
lazy array
lazy constant array
i mean basically every well constant
array
i think lazy center a doesn't make much
sense
lazy subdivide you're right you're right
it doesn't matter probably doesn't make
much sense it's just kind of range what
about sparser rain lazily sparse to raid
i think that i don't think that's
coherent
i mean that's a whole other data
structure that's a whole other data
structure all right okay
you have a lazy list of
array rules
and that's
you know that's what
always is
okay lazy tuples lazy subsets
lazy stub sequences i think is that
right or does lazy subsequences not make
sense
i don't actually know what subsequences
does
and i can guess what it does but
in which case i guess it probably would
make sense although there aren't that
many subsequences
no i think it's much less necessary
because you're not going to generate a
large collection
lazy permutations make sense
and lazy groupings make sense
yes lazy outer
no i was saying i don't think lazy outer
makes a whole lot of sense i mean maybe
but
well
well if you enter linear algebra
this gets very slippery
and we and we get very close to inactive
right
okay what about lazy fix point list
barely
yeah
nest wireless probably
well christopher your estimate of 10 is
not far off
well but i mean we are pretty much with
few exceptions
this list on the left is just generated
from the one on the right by prefixing
lazy so i wonder whether it's really
worth the trouble whether we shouldn't
have no no
no no no no no the whole point is what
we're asking is
is there a you know just like with trees
just like with grafts there are things
which are almost the same but we choose
to have a limited number of functions
because by doing this
we are defining there are certain
functions that work there are other
functions that don't like we've said
lazy you know center array doesn't make
sense so we don't provide it otherwise
if we did a rapper where people would
say lazy of santa right and then they'd
be upset that it doesn't work
see what i'm saying well but yes
more philosophically though i think it's
just like you know for example we have a
nice analogy between associations and
lists and a lot of operations on lists
also work on associations and those are
you know that's how you do it but we
also have a lot of constructors for you
know associations
that are analogous to constructors for
lists but where you know we don't use
like a headdress to specify them i mean
we could have something like association
of thread or association of man and this
corresponds to association throughout an
association map but those are just
different functions that produce a
different data structure so we give them
their own name yes i mean generally
using the data
structure name in a constructor does
make sense so i'm not
i'm not okay so then in this case not
much opposed to it that just thought
that we could save some some work but
okay certainly not work
but but i mean in okay so
certainly not work because each of these
has to be custom implemented anyway
right so i mean then each one of these
would generate a lazy list
and the lazy list would by default as a
next implementation
would display as a blob it might have
some kind of um
i might have some kind of interactive
behavior where you can explore more of
it
making sense see the thing that's
worrying me is that we're going to need
a lazy expression in the end
see what i'm saying
that's why my initial suggestion was
basically treat any whole symbol
withhold as a lazy data stretch well but
then the problem is we don't have date
we don't have operation
if you just say it's a general
expression it's like okay then what's
the api for this what can you query from
what are the set of operations it's just
so amorphous
it's like you can we can map over hold
right
i mean sure i mean there are operations
like i mean if you assume
that it's list like you know then sure
you can map over it but again
you still have to make i mean just as we
were talking about earlier with trees
versus graphs versus arrays whatever you
have to decide where you're sort of
cauterizing it where sort of the you
know the lazy edges are and i think
doing that with a general expression is
very hard i mean unless you just say
it's like the trees you know it's lazy
in the leaves or something like that
but okay so the advantage of a lazy list
is we know the struct the basic shape of
the list
we know
we don't know its elements necessarily
or how big it is but we know kind of
what its shape is what what's overall
you know
i know what you want to call it you know
it's um
it's not going to have any surprises and
that's where graph is more complicated
because it might loop back on itself and
so on
so
and any expression as a tree
right but even our lazy trees though i
mean i guess we could have a tree that's
doubly lazy in the sense that like
even our trees though our trees are not
lazy in the number in the list of leaves
they're only like they're not lazy in
width they're only lazy in depth if that
makes sense or they're not lazy in
length i should say they're only lazy in
depth yeah so i could maybe have one
that is dual lazy or it's lazy both in
the width and the length and the depth
but i think
i don't even know i mean i guess we
could have various three sorts of
operations that go on that but i'm not
even sure how useful that is when i
first
when i first implemented treefold that's
exactly what it was it was it was lazy
in both the depth and in and it
contained a lazy list of children
and we decided to wait
uh
before going down that road any further
but okay so this did it seem promising
or did it did it have some horrible
problem
or was it too early to say it's kind of
too early to say
okay
could also have
a lazy list of
children at a given node
right which is a different concept
also the idea was you know basically
with nest tree that gives you the
laziness and the depth and the idea was
if you wanted to have a
lazy generator for the children you
would just
you know use nest lists or whatever to
generate the children yeah exactly
rather than having treatment
simultaneously doing both yes i think
that's right
right so i mean
lazy tree
i mean when we have nest tree for
example
not necessary tree level for instance
okay trade level tree level on a lazy
tree
would specify how many levels and what
the traversal order is and then it would
evaluate
down to that point in the lazy tree
right
yep
i wanted to make a point earlier too
that i think the traversal order belongs
in the function that consumes a lazy
tree not in the lazy tree itself
i agree with you
um
i mean the lazy tree is just the
infinite tree basically
or however or however far the tree goes
so
the constructor
for a lazy tree would be what lazy nest
i'm forgetting all of our constructors
lazy nest tree right
yeah
we could also have
it doesn't make sense random lazy random
tree doesn't quite make sense except for
random treatment i mean if we say lazy
hairy tree
does that make sense
so i'm saying if i if i say a character
an infinite binary tree what's that
i think so
yeah because that's only lazy in the
depths isn't it
yeah
i mean is that the um what complete k
airy tree also
complete carry tree is the depth carey
tree would be the number of nodes
remember this function i guess the thing
you'd really want is just to say
complete carry area tree and then you
just give it k and the depth is infinity
or something yeah exactly
right
aka
infinite
carey tree although although actually i
i maybe take it back a little bit
because
it seems like one of the things we've
been talking about like for example the
xml case is that there is value in
having lazy but finite stuff although
we've been a little bit interchangeable
with lazy versus infinite
yeah
yes and and you're right
or the truth we need not only lazy tree
but like the lazy
uh you know
tree expression to a different kind of
tree expression
and we have an internal function called
expression transform that's eager but it
could have a lazy
version i don't understand so i'm sorry
back up for a second
so
in the in trees you can have expression
tree and tree expression
right
so that that leads to the idea of having
a lazy expression tree composed with a
lazy tree expression
and what would that do
that would you're saying it will make
the transformation
between anything expression tree can
understand any other thing that
expression tree can understand well like
we could do that with map as well
you could you could take a you know a
next lazy expression right
if you had a lazy expression
you could imagine doing a map on a lazy
expression
of certain parts of the expression
i don't know whether this is useful
see what i'm saying i mean i think this
might be what nick was talking about
here was it nick
oh yeah pretty close
yes
i'm pretty close i'm implementing that
what's that you know i'm pretty close to
implementing that all of this
right
it's not that far off from the lazy tree
that they have
it's just maybe different in formatting
yeah yeah i understand
i understand
i mean i think the thing that'd be
really good if you were to implement is
just get these things basically
implemented
returning a lazy list which is just a
blob
you know what i'm saying and where you
do normal of it lazy list would have
certain
uh properties that you can extract
but if you say length and so on if many
eager operations
can be just done
it has up values for many kinds of
operations like length for example
does that make sense
yeah
well landfill it would probably
problematic
why i
i know because if you have a sub value
for lazy list caused some issues there
are other codes there
because it's
sometimes in one actual
because some of the code that they use
already uses length of the expression
right and if
and if it's a lazy list
we have to solve the problem i mean you
know so
so
there are ego versions
like things like length
of lazy list
that needs to just work
perhaps this means these objects are
atomic
yeah i think they probably are i think
they are autonomic i don't think we
should i don't think we should have
anything which where you can go in and
take the seventh element because lazy
list
stub
10 to the 5 10 to the 4 or something
whoops
should just do that it should just go in
and figure out how to get the 10 to the
fourth element
right it shouldn't in any way pretty
much
laser listed any list of any operations
on list that can obviously work should
yeah just via up values right
yes obviously right
i mean
the thing that i wonder i still come
back to should lazy length of lazy of
the spear transfinite number
or should it just be
it's always going to be countable i mean
with at least the lazy list that we're
talking about but other lazy lists that
might be different but the lazy list
that we're talking about is always
countable isn't it yes but so it's
well
but but
like
a lazy list of lazy lists is omega
squared
list what's that you don't know it's a
lazy list of lazy lists maybe the first
billion elements are our lazy lists and
then and then after that they're not and
there's also the fact that i think we
talked about how length should just you
know
because if you want length to work in
the finite lazy list case
then
you know you can't have it just return
infinity immediately
no
but i would assume that one property of
all these objects is that they have a
definite length which might be infinite
but it's definite it might even be
symbolic
well but i don't think you can do that
because like for example if you do
something like length you know for
example suppose i you know consider the
following lazy list i i say uh infinite
range i map prime over that so i have
now an infinite list of primes or or i
maybe implement some prime sieve or
something like that with a select
and then i say uh or i say select prime
you know infinite range color prime q
length of that you know knowing that's
infinite is
non-trivial
i mean insert a joke about zeta function
or something right well twin primes twin
primes you just can't do it it doesn't
know
right
i mean the question is do these lazy
lists have some optional meta
information like if we know the length
we could store it and then this could it
could say infinite
and if you have an infinite lazy list
and you do a select on it and then you
ask for the length of that resulting uh
lazy list it could say indeterminate
because it doesn't know
possibly yes i mean like i mean i feel
like it's it's a little weird to have
these sort of it sometimes has a length
and it sometimes doesn't
well it just we don't know but
i mean if if we don't know and i ask for
the length then i have to be prepared to
wait
until it has counted the elements and
well if you say range of infinity you
should say the length of the range of
infinity is infinity sure i mean in many
cases we can
but obviously once you start
applying operations that transform like
a lazy list into other lazy lists you
may lose so so there's some there's some
operations that preserve the length of
the list
mapping something over the list
preserves the length of the list
selecting does not preserve the length
of the list therefore
length can no longer be certain of what
the length is yes and so the question is
do we just provide as much information
as we have if we know that
a list is infinite
then we can kind of think probably yes
but we need to actually try it
otherwise if we do that and then it's
just too easy to
accidentally type lengths of some lazy
list and then a minute later you have to
avoid your computation
so
there there's a
no having length loop forever is stupid
yeah i mean so what do we do
do we just say if we don't know the
length
then just
give it a give it i'm sorry actually
wait a minute but if i say if i say if i
say lazy range of you know then i ask to
make a thing of length 10 and i ask for
length of that
i mean i they're going to return
indeterminate or it's going to also guys
loop forever guys
no no look guys guys
look there are cases where we know it's
infinite and it's trivially provable
that it is infinite
and as we do operations on
the on a lazy list we should store in
the metadata whether the operation that
we did is a one-to-one operation like
map for example
okay if it is you can keep it as
infinite if it's a select
well then there might be some theorem
you could prove or you might just give
up and say we don't know the length
maybe i i just predict that two things
one i predict that that it's going to be
i i predict it's going to be kind of uh
it's going to make it much more
painful and it's going to be much
heavier weight thing if every time you
sort of implement a different operation
on one of these you kind of have to uh
at least for the primitives you're going
to have to uh you know
to include information you know all
sorts of meta information for now it's
the length but maybe in the future it'll
be something else too and then the other
thing
yeah go ahead
no go ahead go ahead isn't it all the
case that
a typical program on lazy lists
would never ask for the length
what why would it do so
i mean that
seems an operation that you just don't
do unless if you if no that's not
correct
if the list is
let's say you do a select
of the lazy subsets
let's say just as your selective lazy
subsets with some function
and you expect that the answer is a
million
but the subsets there were 10 to the 10
to the 20s i don't know let's say let's
say there were 10 to the 12 subsets that
were generated and you believe that the
answer for that length thing will be a
million
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
ask for
the the computer runs overnight
you know enumerating each of those
trillion you know subsets
and then you've done this lazy select so
to speak the select on the lazy object
and then you can count the results and
there are a million of them now i admit
that in that case the results that
you're getting are a non-lazy set of
results
otherwise you don't know the answer
here's maybe a more a more
programmably practical example would be
something like
i'm i'm reading a big file and i'm i'm
reading it as some sort of lazy list
you know the length you or lazy string
right you probably know the length in a
string it's probably more complicated
actually because there are things like
the way unicode works and so on but but
but
for a list
uh well actually i guess it depends on
what the list is of maybe maybe i i
maybe never mind i was going to say you
might know the length of the file yeah
you might from some system call that
sort of out but if you just know the
number of bytes it doesn't you know
unless you're you're you're importing it
as a lazy
list of bytes
um you're probably
not gonna know well
that's not a realistic example there is
the possibility of you know not that we
necessarily want to do it but there's
also a lazy bite array
uh relevant for importing like that but
you couldn't yeah i mean we because we
already have so many
i mean
i think that shouldn't stop because we
already have exactly because we have so
many by the way operations i mean also
because i think the whole point of bite
arrays is that they're low level and
fast and
you know
i think yeah that's too weird the point
of that yeah fine i suspect lazy string
is seriously interesting
that one i think it's interesting
because
you know it's one of these things where
you could go examine the string you
could be streaming through
some very complicated file looking for
some particular thing you could imagine
doing a grep basically wouldn't that
pretty much be the same as the
lazy list of the characters of the
string
no
no not in practice
because look imagine you've got a
terrible light sized file and you want
to search for every element of
every word that occurs just before
rhinoceros
okay that's a finite case so i mean one
question is what string operations would
be defined on an infinite string so as i
mean there's certainly lots of things
yeah okay i'll give you an example um
the weather reports
from
random airports they're going to keep
coming forever presumably yeah that's
not a function i mean i'm asking like
string cases you know is there a usage
of string cases that makes sense on on
an infinite string like we certainly
have kate things like that like string
cases would probably make a lot of sense
on a very big so you want it to be lazy
but still finite string yes but i'm
asking about the infinite case
i admit that the only infinite case that
i can think of is this one where there's
a stream streaming data and that
streaming data has has just keeps going
forever
but what function i mean
no i understand i don't know how to i
don't know how to return the only
function that i can imagine is uh first
position of rhinoceros
and it keeps going until it finds the
first rhinoceros
okay sure
sure
i'm not sure we have an existing string
function for that but yeah
well operation that might on infinite
strings
what do we we do have that i mean in a
sense that's the
that string cases comma one i think
does string cases have a thing where you
can tell it how many cases defined
pretty sure
cases does
oh you're right it's third argument at
the end
sure
so so i guess on the other usages though
i guess it would just hope that it's
finite
yeah
so it'll probably run forever if it's
infinite if it doesn't know if it's
infinite or finite
right right but i mean it's just going
to keep looking right it's going to keep
looking for a rhinoceros or it's going
to keep looking for a for a yeti or
something if it doesn't find the yeti
it's just going to keep looking
um
okay we're not going to get too much
further here today but i do just want to
set
our
[Music]
so i think we've got a pretty reasonable
approach here to the lazy stuff although
i don't like the word lazy but i think
we should start implementing with that
word in there
i think
the next big thing
uh
is
you know computation objects
of which our friend trace graph i mean
again we went through this last time
right i hope we haven't forgotten those
notes here
where is the um
where where is that where are those
notes
notes please
of if notes from last time sw notes 01
were your notes from the last stream
you have it open
okay
yeah there may be some operations i
don't know what lazy split says i i
think i remember for last time there may
be a few
things which are operations on lazy
objects which are new constructs
beyond
the ones we already know
okay this isn't what i was talking about
maybe it's the one before
i was talking about is when we talk
about look
okay a computation object
this is what i was talking about before
remember rules
function
evaluation the constructor right
constructor has the version of
you know it's like
do you remember what i'm talking about
nick you remember what i'm talking
i about the same thing
for us for the lazy objects
no not really i mean we've got no we've
got the concept of well maybe yes
we've got iterate
um
oh if it's a constructor maybe it's some
kind of maybe a
buff we went through this before we went
through this before can we please find
the notes from this
we went through this exact thing before
and this is what we need to actually go
ahead and implement now
right we talked about how we can get it
with rule application we can get it with
function
application and we can get it with down
values am i making sense
oh yeah i see
right those are the cases
and each one of those
you know will basically making
a
uh
but isn't it the construction of a lazy
object not a computational chip
no this is also a computational object
okay you're right we could do this as a
lazy object too but we also want the
computation object so we want
just like you can say lazy nest list
actually we don't want laziness list
we want lazy nest
it's something like this but that's not
the actual right term
lazy nest object f of a net
okay and that becomes
a computation object or something maybe
it's for now we call it lazy computation
object
am i making sense
yeah i don't understand how this
different from the just lazy object then
if you specify a function but because
because i'm telling you because it
contains okay
the lazy object is the output
okay the output
it's the lazy list it's the output it's
the result of running nest list or
whatever it is or nest whatever
the output not how you got there just
the output just like every other
function in the system is just the
output
what i'm saying where it's like you
return an initial lazy object which
has evaluated none times zero times
this is the computational object and
then you know it's not no it's not no
it's not it's a generator it's not got
the it's the difference between nest and
nest list
okay
nest
just gives you the result
right nest list gives you a trace of how
you got there
am i making sense
so one of these things just gives you
the result the result happens to be a
lazy object that contains a generator
that when you poke at that lazy object
when you inspect the lazy object it
might have to go run the generator
further
okay okay so
lazy object is just a part of a
computational object
right at least that is correct yes it's
a it is the result it is the
you know for example a lazy object might
be
it might be a slice of a computation
object or it might be the fixed point of
the computation object
does that make sense
no a slice of a computation object
computation object is the running
computation okay
it is a computation that can be
continued it can be run you know okay
and so this slice is something like this
right that's a slice of a computation
object
it's just there also can be a slice of
laser it's like
computational i i know but
you're a lazy object what's metadata
the important point about a lazy object
is
it may not all have been computed yet
but if you said normal on it
it's just boom it's all there and it
contains no history
you see what i'm saying
yeah
right whereas a computation object which
we have never had in the system before
right the lazy object we have
no we've had things a bit like it like
sparse array and things like that
making sense
the only thing we've had that is even
vaguely like
a
a computational object is nest list or
nest graph
right but they're not very adequate
because they don't have event
information
nest's graph only has state information
making sense
yeah yeah sure
i understand
so well in practice i i would implement
computational which is just
some lazy object with metadata you can
continue a computation you can
store its history take slices and so on
yeah exactly there's no there's nothing
but but the whole point is that there is
a conceptual difference between
the lazy object which is just the output
right that we don't where we don't but
we happen not to have generated it all
yet but it is an output object
okay and and then this now in the
computation object
we then have functions like
find path
like
uh
now you know it's a different thing in
the in the lazy object
we have things like find the average
value
right it could work across the infinite
and infinite lazy object potentially
we can estimate that somehow
and
i i really think i think this is this is
about right now the difference the thing
that we've got
in
rule application function application
down values
is
each one of those
has
a
traversal order
which could be a single way traversal
order
but it's it's an you know it's otherwise
known as event selection function for
the multi-rate system it could be a
single way thing or it could be a
multi-way thing with a certain choice of
of sort of foliation
does that make sense
i'm sure yeah
selection function
right
but now the tricky thing about the
foliations
in the case of rule application
and down values
okay the case of function application
[Music]
all we have
is potentially okay so look if if we say
function application
gives
time like extent
and branch-like extent
because the function application we're
assuming
that's the case where the function
maps you know x
to
the list you know abc
you see what i'm saying
okay so that's a branch-like extent but
there is no space like extent here
in the case of
of uh rural application
or for the replace
case
there is also
just time like and branch branch-like
whether they replace all case
there is also space like
am i making sense
well we can also say for for function
application that map all
is also have a space like extent
yes if we use map all
xxx
will also have space like
okay now there isn't a big distinction
here in the case of function application
between branch-like and rule-like
because in the case i've just described
there
that is in fact you know that's also got
really an extent
because they're different rules right
well
i wouldn't
really distinguish that
i know i know but i can really get the
same in this case
no i mean even for the rules if you have
just a multiple rules i wouldn't
distinguish it with some think overall
that just have a more complicated path
on the left hand side
possibly that's true i don't know what i
think one might consider one branch like
one will like but anyway i mean so we've
got rule applications so we've got these
different cases which are all where we
can where we need to be able to control
in each case
we've got to define what is the
foliation that we're going to use
well maybe we don't have to define that
when we're just defining the computation
object maybe the foliation is in the eye
of the observer so to speak
remember making sense
yeah
and so then we want these three cases of
creating computational objects in these
three different ways and let's not
shoehorn them together because they're
not going to fit
do you see what i'm saying
yeah so we can have
lazy evaluate that produces a
does not lazy evaluate i don't think
it's lazy evaluated i think that's a
mistake to call it that
i think it's it's
yeah i mean i don't know it's it's it's
i mean i don't know whether this is kind
of like a
well for now we can call them them just
to easily place ways to
let's call it
let's not apply it's lazy construct
it's not it isn't even that it's because
it's got lists in it
well i mean
this should really be an object we
should say
because it's really different from a
you get what i'm saying it's making the
thing with the history which is not the
same meaning as lazy for a lazy list
this is the result of function
i know but it
shouldn't be called lazy apply then it
should be called something different
yeah
i don't know
okay so it's something like lazy apply
process or something
that's not the right name for it but you
know it's something which is a process
not
it's a representation of a process not
just the result
am i making sense
okay but i agree that these so if we
have these
then we need the functions that you've
already started building like find path
and so on and then we also need
ian's trace graph
and we should have a version of trace
graph for each of these cases
am i making sense
right we built the one for evaluation we
need to build these other ones as well
do you get what i'm saying yeah yeah i
get it yeah
yeah you get it
that that's not for me to do though
no
but it will be informed by what you have
and i want to make sure you understand
what this is
i mean trace graph is
essentially
a hierarchical thing it's showing the
nested evaluation chains and and things
like replace all aren't necessarily
going to have
nested structure like that no no no no
no no they are they are they are it's
going to be
okay you've got you've got a different
thing you've got
tree-like in addition to the space-like
recursion you've got tree-like recursion
into expressions
okay the graph that you're making
should look like up to the fact that it
deals with
sub-expressions
on the expression tree
it is just like
if if all it dealt with was hypographs
okay rather than expression trees
i believe it will be exactly like what
we have in the physics project with
space like time-like branch-like edges
am i making sense
yep
so
it's it's not
the trace graph is not strictly
like a expression tree thing it's
a subsidiary evaluations like that also
covers non-standard evaluation
sorry say it again
so
the the trace graph is not necessarily
just about expression recursion
it's about an evaluation that requires
subsidiary evaluations which sometimes
is just
expression recursion but not always
i understand because it's because it has
events
look in in the events that happened
there
an event could consume stuff
yeah that is expressions that came from
non-substantive places i think i mean i
yeah but i mean in the case of
function application i believe that is a
pure multi-way graph of the kind that
we've always had
do you agree
uh nick do you agree or other people
here do you agree
yeah it's always
you know this case is just a much regret
in the case of function application okay
so that this
here
the
evaluation graph for the the um the
execution graph
is just a multi-ray graph
and again it can have you know the
variance of that like a token event
graph and so on can be there too right
in that case the token the events are
rather trivial now every edge has an
event on it
am i correct
okay
so in the case of rule application
it's not just an ordinary multi-way
graph it's not it's just this is in a
sense a state's multi-way graph
this is something beyond that right
well you know in what exact sense so
for example rules can grow up
yeah which means that it's a
look as we said here
i i don't know we gotta just start
generating some of these things
the evaluation case is what ian has
already handled no he hasn't handled
he's handled the value
ian
has
the single way version of this
making sense
the evaluation that shows spatial
recursion
and time-like recursion
but it doesn't show
the multi-way stuff right it doesn't
show the branchial
edge of it you know bronchial extent
oh god i've got to go um
sorry guys
uh all right we've made some good
progress here let's keep let's keep
going on this i mean so nick if you can
try and implement some of the things
we've talked about here and
you know
does that make sense
yeah yeah sure
okay
and let's you know let's let's make sure
we follow this
and when we add if you want to add a
swiss army knife add it in a different
place
that makes sense so we really make sure
we have these functions are very clean
and well defined
you can put the the innards of a
laziness can be full of swiss army
i don't know whether the
roman can perhaps tell us more about the
history of the swiss army knife
and whether we're do they assume them to
people in the swiss army
well yes yes
do they have like particularly fancy
ones well no no i mean those are very
very basic i mean they
they are they have to be practical and
robust and
they don't need usb sticks and
10 different school drivers
i mean
they're enough
and they don't have a horse hoof
thing they always used to have thing for
cleaning up horse's hooves or something
maybe they lost that
um no that that must be a long time ago
no more
um
okay
all right i gotta go um thanks guys and
to be continued